- When I was a kid, I used
to wonder how it was possible
that the Roman Republic could just fall.
The Roman Republic and
the Roman Empire stood
for hundreds of years, and
yet it all came crashing down.
My history teacher would say,
"The barbarians invaded,"
but in truth, it collapsed
from the inside out
because when Caesar crossed the Rubicon,
it was clear, the rule of
law didn't matter anymore,
and that was the beginning of the end
because the rule of law matters.
The mission of LegalEagle
is to explain our laws,
to explain how the system
works, when it works.
It's not my place to tell you
what policies our
politicians should adopt,
but as a lawyer with an inside
view to our judicial system,
I think I have an insight
into at least this aspect
of our government.
And over the last four years,
one thing has become clear.
President Trump doesn't
care about the law.
He's ignorant of the law and
actively subverts the law.
He uses the law for his own
gain and he breaks the law
when it stands in his way.
If you care about the
rule of law in America,
you cannot, in good conscience,
vote for Donald Trump.
This video is not about politics per se.
It's not about liking or
disliking the legislation
that President Trump has signed,
it's not about liking or disliking the way
he has handled the COVID-19 epidemic,
nor is it about liking
or disliking the judges
that he has appointed.
This video is about the rule of law.
It's about legal equity
and legal equality,
and it's about justice.
And I guess, when the
Scientific American breaks
with 175 years of tradition to endorse
a presidential candidate, I guess no one
including the lawyers, can
stand idly by on the sideline.
So for the first, and
hopefully only time, LegalEagle
endorses a presidential candidate.
LegalEagle endorses Joe
Biden for president.
He is the only candidate that has any hope
of upholding the rule
of law in this country.
Why? Because president
Donald Trump is a criminal.
We know this to an almost certainty.
There's so much evidence
hiding in plain sight
that it's actually
sometimes hard to remember
everything that he's done.
But before we vote in
November, let's at least try.
You might recall that
President Trump is actually
un-indicted co-conspirator individual
number one to the conspiracy
Michael Cohen has already
pleaded guilty to,
regarding the illegal hush
money payments to porn stars.
Michael Cohen, the
president's former attorney,
pleaded guilty to eight criminal charges.
Five counts of tax evasion, one count
of making false statements
to a financial institution,
one count of willfully causing
an unlawful corporate contribution,
and one count of making an
excessive campaign contribution
at the request of President
Trump, for the principle purpose
of influencing the election.
Michael Cohen went to
jail for those crimes
and committed those crimes
at the direction of the President.
But now President Trump
did not go to jail.
He stayed in office, but
that doesn't make him
any less guilty than the
people that he directed.
And after president
Trump stayed in office,
he tried to use $400
million in taxpayer funds
allocated for the defense of Ukraine
to fabricate dirt on
his political opponent.
Effectively, the President
tried to blackmail
a strategic partner using taxpayer funds
into soliciting a bribe
for his own benefit
and not for nothing, to
try and create exactly
the kind of narrative
that he was able to use
in 2016 against his former opponent.
- It was beautiful. It was
just a perfect conversation.
- After the scheme was
discovered, the President
then punished the whistle-blowers
who brought it to the public's attention.
Apart from the illegality,
this is the kind of malfeasance
that goes straight to the
heart of our democracy.
This is about interfering
with the voters' choice.
This is about creating black propaganda
for one's own benefit.
And this is about using the
funds, the mighty forces
of the United States for
one's own personal benefit.
And you might recall that the
Watergate break-in occurred
because President Nixon
wanted an election advantage.
Do not forget that President
Trump was impeached.
However, he was not removed,
but that doesn't mean
that his actions were neither
impeachable nor illegal.
It means that certain political figures
made a political decision
to allow him to stay.
And if our political leaders
don't have the stones
to do anything about it and would rather
we just forgot the whole affair,
it's our job to remember when we vote.
And we've been lucky that
much of the President's
illegality has been
boneheaded and incompetent,
but we might not be so lucky next time.
And that's how we bungled our way
into the (indistinct) scandal
of the Trump administration.
When the president started to politicize
the entire enforcement wing
of the executive branch,
when the president fired
the director of the FBI
specifically because he was investigating
the president's ties to Russia,
then the president told
the Russians in a secret
Oval Office meeting,
"I faced great pressure
because of Russia.
That's taken off."
And then the president
admitted to the entire thing
to Lester Holt on national television.
- When I decided to just do it
I said to myself, I said, you know
this Russia thing with Trump
and Russia is a made-up story.
It's an excuse by the Democrats
for having lost an election
that they should've won.
- And then as we know,
from the Mueller report
there was an entire scheme
to cover all of this up.
The Mueller report is
practically a flashing red siren
that says that the president
and his accomplices
engaged in an obstruction
of justice on par
or worse than the Watergate scandal.
And yet for prudential
reasons they decided
not to refer it for
prosecution, hoping that
the legislative branch
would do something about it.
And of course, unfortunately they did not.
But that doesn't change the impropriety
of the underlying conduct.
And the second half of the Mueller report
is almost equally damning.
That even if the Trump administration
and the Trump organization did not engage
in actual conspiracy and
collusion with the Russians,
they still solicited and
encouraged illegal hacking
for their own personal gain
and certainly benefited from that hacking.
And then of course there's a whole raft
of pettier, but equally
damning malfeasance.
For example, the president's
solicitation of emoluments.
Now, granted, there are open
questions about the limits
of the emoluments clause
in the Constitution
but it's clear that the
President has more conflicts
of interest than any president in history.
The President owns and
operates myriad businesses
while holding office which is rife
for conflicts of interest.
Hundreds of thousands of
dollars have been spent
by the US military under extraordinarily
suspicious circumstances at the
Trump Turnberry Golf Resort,
and failing to divest
himself has left himself open
to bribes from every
visiting politician in DC
who love to brag about
staying in the Trump DC hotel
and from every foreign business
partner, including China,
where the president holds
an undisclosed bank account,
potentially to hide
foreign corrupt practices.
- Can you imagine if I had had
a secret Chinese bank account
when I was running for reelection?
You think Fox news might have been
a little concerned about that?
- The president has asked
his attorney general
to interfere with the
prosecution of Trump loyalists.
The president has gassed
protesters exercising
their first amendment
rights to get a photo op
in Lafayette square.
The president has sent federal
troops into cities on a whim.
He's turned the government
into his own personal campaign
and fails to punish government employees
who violate the Hatch Act.
And again, this goes to
the heart of the democracy.
Incumbents get a huge
advantage by operating
the levers of the government.
And he seems to operate
the entire US government
as his own personal reelection campaign,
which is probably good because
the last three campaign heads
that he's had are actual convicted felons,
or in the case of Brad Parscale
are about to be felons.
The president has almost surely engaged
in manifests tax evasion.
He likes to pardon and
commute the sentences
of his cronies who have
engaged in real illegality,
obstruction of justice and
lying to the government.
And as part of that, he has politicized
the Department of Justice,
leading to investigations
for his own political
gain and retribution.
He interferes with the
prosecution of his friends
and business partners.
And unfortunately, this
is the tip of the iceberg,
because the president has fired most
of the inspectors general,
often after they have found
improprieties within the
Trump administration.
And lest we forget one of the
most disgusting things he said.
He admitted to forcible sexual assault
before he was elected the first time.
- I don't even know,
and when you're a star,
they let you do it.
You can do anything.
- Whatever you want.
- Grabbing by the (beep)
do any of that. (laughter)
- The president doesn't deserve
the benefit of the doubt.
He had his chance.
And at least in this respect, he was worse
than a lot of us could have imagined.
This is apart from issues
of politics or competence.
I wouldn't fault you at all
if you chose not to vote for Trump
because of his politics, but
it's not my role as a lawyer
and legal commentator to tell you
about your political beliefs.
And similarly, I might
agree with you, if you felt
he didn't deserve the vote because
he was wildly incompetent,
like either ignores his
daily classified briefings
or requires them to be in
picture book format incompetent
or injecting disinfectant
into your veins incompetent.
- Injection inside, or almost a cleaning.
Again I say, maybe you
can, maybe you can't,
I'm not a doctor.
I'm like a person that
has a good you know what,
or like staring into a
solar eclipse incompetent.
But what I am saying is that
some things are apolitical
or that even if you agree
100% with what the President
stands for from a political perspective,
perhaps there are more important things,
like the rule of law.
The problem is that once you lose it,
you never get it back.
And there is a barbarian
in the White House.
President Trump is not the
candidate of law and order.
He cares about a certain
kind of order all right,
but not the law.
A vote for President Trump is a vote
that says the law doesn't matter.
It's a vote that says it's okay
if the rich and powerful
use the law unequally.
It's a vote that says
criminals will not be punished.
But that only happens if we allow it.
I still believe the law matters.
I still believe in equal protection.
I still believe in justice.
And I hope you do too.
And I hope that you consider
the rule of law when you vote.